station Chief Dan Hoffman he's also a
Fox News contributor and I'm curious
what you think about that leak from last
night that came out from the
administration suggesting that Iran
really had nothing no idea that this was
going on and it was almost as if they
were trying to give Iran cover that they
didn't know that they allow as I said on
Martha's show um they let the kids have
a keger and then pretended to know
nothing about
it yeah well that's a distinction
without a difference because none of
those proxy terrorist groups would exist
without Iran's support Iran provides
them with military equipment with all
the missiles that they need with
intelligence support with financial
support and so Iran might not have told
them when to strike but Iran was
certainly uh providing them with all of
that support because those groups
intended to strike us and let's just be
clear we are at war with Iran it's a
proxy war right now uh but with there is
a war going on and it's happening
because the houthis Lebanese hisbah is
targeting Israel and remember that this
all started 40 years ago when hisbah uh
the predecessor terrorist group to
hisbah launched an attack on the Marine
Barracks and then our Embassy in Beirut
that's the way Iran operates that's the
way they conduct War all right anybody
got a question for Dan Hoffman Dan I'll
follow up on what we talked about
earlier we we talked about all these
guys scattered around all these bases in
um Syria and Iraq that are the target of
these attacks what are they
accomplishing having a presence in Syria
and Iraq
well look we've got a couple of
interests important National Security
interests in the Middle East one is
freedom of navigation there's a lot of
trade that happens through the Red Sea
and then in Syria and Iraq very small
numbers of US troops 2 200 in Iraq just
a few hundred in Syria they're there to
do counterterrorism operations they're
not there to bring democracy to the
Middle East they're not there to build
girls schools but they are there to
protect us here at home because there
are terrorists uh Al-Qaeda and Isis
terrorists there and if we we don't
Target them way out there left of Boom
then they're going to Target Us in the
region and potentially here at home look
I served in those places I served in
Iraq for a year I served in South Asia
as a station chief for two years uh we
were always perfectly fine serving in
harms way as long as uh we had the right
equipment to keep us as safe as possible
as well as the right policy and that's
what has been lacking uh over the past
certainly few months where 160 plus
strikes against our people and we've
lost escalation dominance uh to
Iran uh you know Dan Janine pero here
the the whole idea of our policy you
know of allowing how many uh I think
it's like 80 or 100 who were injured
some with traumatic brain injuries in
Iraq and Syria before this last attack
where three were were killed and 40
injured how much influence has the
commercial interference of shipping had
on the American policy I mean because
it's almost like you see the commercial
MK apparently is not going through the
Red Sea now they're going around the
Cape of Africa I mean is it is do do you
see policy changing when it comes to
commercial vessels and countries getting
a little more aggressive then as opposed
to when Americans are injured because
I'm not convinced this Administration is
so concerned about Americans when we
allowed 160 attacks on our servicemen in
Syria and
Iraq well I'm sure the administration
and I'm sure that uh that those who are
serving in the administration are very
concerned about uh US servicemen and
women and others who are serving In
Harm's Way I think they're also
concerned overriding concern for them is
not to escalate uh and and result in a
in a war with Iran and I think that
they've overplayed that by a lot for
sure there's interest in Freedom of
navigation you're absolutely 100% right
about that the world World economy will
suffer greatly because of these houy
terrorists and one more thing that I
would add is that if you don't strike
back early then the price of deterrence
just goes up and so the price of
deterring the houthis has gone way up
over the past couple of months as well
as dealing with those uh Iranian proxy
terrorists in uh in Syria and in Iraq
who were targeting us there we have to
pay a much greater price today Dan the
10 billion waiver that the Biden
Administration gave to Iran is still in
effect tonight
yeah and we know where the money goes
Dana it's uh straight to Iran's
ballistic missile program it's their
nuclear program and it's the proxy
terrorist so it's got to be an all of
government approach here the doj uh
seizing of the of of $500,000 worth of
Iranian oil is is a good first albeit
small step uh but there's got to be a
lot more they've got to cut off uh
Iran's access to funds because we know
what they're doing with it un
fortunately uh Russia and China as well
as North Korea and Iran make up this
Century's axis of tyranny that's been
one of the results of of the the war in
Gaza and Russia's brutal barbaric war in
Ukraine and that's just another wickedly
complex challenge for this
Administration Dan thank you it's also
another reason why I brought up um hi
everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now